c'est la route de la liberté le
brésilien d'entrée en inde les 31
réfugiés sont passés il ne risque plus
rien
il y à un mois et fuyait le tibet à pied
à travers ces montagnes qui s'éloigne
trop loin
ce matin ils ont réussi à passer la
frontière
épuisé mais heureux dès les premiers
kilomètres les enfants s'endorment bercé
par les chants de joie des adultes
oh
ou pas
je veux recevoir la bénédiction du dalaï
lama
et ensuite c'est possible apprendre à
lire recevoir une formation et commencer
une nouvelle vie
c'est pour ça que je vais à dharamsala
dharamsala est presque une enclave
tibétaine dans le nord de l'inde c'est
là que vit le dalaï lama guide spirituel
des exilés tibétains son monastère à
flanc de colline et tournée vers
l'himalaya frontière avec le tibet qu'il
a fuie lui aussi il ya cinquante ans
après deux jours de bus les nouveaux
arrivants sont accueillis au centre de
réfugiés
les âmes au rez-de-chaussée les femmes à
l'étagé partout des enfants c'est ce qui
nous frappe d'emblée certains os 6 ou 7
ans aussi on marche et un mois pour
arriver là
ma maman m'a dit que je partais pour
pouvoir aller à l'école elle me manque
[Musique]
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est devenir
moine
[Musique]
nous découvrons que ses enfants sont
seuls ici
leurs parents les ont confiés à des
passeurs dans l'espoir d'une vie
meilleure
conti landuré pour en arriver là que
peuvent-ils espérer loin des leurs sur
cette terre des îles qui surnomme le
petit tibet
la liberté 10 les plus grands les
enfants eux ne savent pas ce qui les
attend pendant trois mois nous allons le
découvrir avec eux
[Musique]
le dalaï lama à cheval et à dharamsala
en 1960 son gouvernement tibétain en
exil avec ses monastères ses écoles son
propre budget l'une de ses premières
missions et d'accueillir tous les
tibétains qui fut la chine plus de
cinquante mille exilés ont été ainsi
prise en charge depuis 20 ans une
organisation sans faille
ils viennent presque tous du tibet ils
ont fui parce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
pratiquer librement leur religion ici
personne ne les embête donc ils sont
restés
et toi qui tu as envoyé ici
mes parents pourquoi
ils m'ont dit qu'ici je pourrais étudier
les textes sacrés
et ce brassard noir c'est quoi c'est en
signe de deuil pour les tibétains
opprimés
reut
les réfugiés tibétains sont considérés
comme des clandestins au népal ce
monastère sert de cache sur la route de
l'exil ou le temps qu'ils finissent leur
formation
d'ordinaire les jeunes moines reste ici
quelques années avant de retourner au
tibet répandre la bonne parole
mais depuis le mois de mars eux aussi
sont bloqués au népal
selon la croyance tibétaine cette
écharpe va vous apporter la chance et
longue vie
voilà j'espère que nous nous reverrons
et au tibet
vraiment
j'aimerais tant mourir au tibet